[Musique]
ça y est ça y est
que le nom du bot show qu'il a les mêmes
yeux comment alors que tout le monde et
c'est tout à fait moi ça j'espère que
c'est la seule chose qui tient de toit
et le petit enfant gardé par qui
les premiers noms tu connais beaucoup de
parents qui laissent leurs enfants à la
mine ou un faux bond mais toujours chez
nous peut que nous ne mélangeons pas
tout
bégin dette c'est qu'ils auraient
préféré
[Musique]
son but je travaille je reviens pourquoi
mon fils il est dans les bras 22.2 gens
qu'on connaît pas là on a plus de vie
parce qu'on veut agir et lui mais
surtout parce qu'on va vous gérez vous
plus bizarre quand il était avec moi ils
purent jamais on a une peur parce qu'ils
s'emmerdent avec toi pardon bah ouais on
est entouré par quatre tard et j'ai
l'impression d'être la seule à mauron
voir passer un permis grands parents un
permis qui prouve que vous êtes à pedro
vous allez avoir passé un séjour
ensemble tous les quatre et sans
embrouille la mission assurer la
sécurité de bout d'chou la sécurité
avant tout
j'ai confiée à maryse up brûlés
complètement
parmi ces quatre choix lequel serait la
meilleure donc toi bats pas tu feras
garder ton petit fils par emile louis je
croyais que c'était joué le rôle du show
[Musique]